it's Mitchell true Biscay versus Nick
falls in Chicago the winner gets a
Waterpik the loser sits on the bench I
had a chance to talk to GM Ryan pace on
Friday about the looming quarterback
competition here's some of what pace had
to say just because we didn't exercise
that fifth-year option doesn't mean that
we don't believe in Mitch I mean we did
the same thing with Kyle fuller a couple
years ago and it worked out really well
for him so mitch is in a position right
now and he knows that Matt and I met
with him and we were transparent we were
honest it's a competition and that's
when I love the way he approached it I
mean I think once he digested it he's
simply kind of seen clenched his jaw and
embrace and hey let's go let's go and I
think it's gonna be fun to see this play
out
and again both of those guys I know it's
been virtual meetings but but Mitch and
Nick have been awesome those meetings
completely engaged competition really
can't start till we start rolling in
training camp but you really like the
mindset of both those players you can
see the full interview at the PFT p.m.
podcast Chris if it's close who who gets
the win that you know they say in
baseball the runner gets to tie if it's
a tie or something close to it who's
gonna be the starter for the Bears week
one I mean I feel like usually the tie
goes to the guy that was there already
or the guy that was the starter in place
right like Mitchell sure Biscay I you
know since he was the starter last year
and they went to the playoffs the year
before that when they get into training
camp he's gonna get the first first
first team reps right he'll get to go
with that you know and again training
camp preseason it's generic you don't
see a lot of crazy defenses so you know
it's hard to separate yourself sometimes
throughout the preseason and training
camp practices and all that so I do
think in a normal setting the guys
that's been there usually gets the the
tie goes with the runner Bennett benefit
their bike but if I'm in Chicago and I
think it's close I'm going wouldn't it
foes I am you know I'll say this again I
think that everybody in that city is
just waiting for Mitchell too risky to
fail if you start him the first time he
throws an incompletion or an
interception or does anything like that
it's going to be bluebirds and get
nicked for
in there I think you're better off if
it's closed going with Nick close see
what he's got
if he stumbles and falls then you bring
true Brisky off the bench and now the
public's not on its back either that
would be mighty see I think if it's
close it does go to Falls because in the
mind of bears coach Matt naggy Falls is
closer to being an incumbent he's the
incumbent in the offense true Biscay is
still the outsider trying to learn it
and not learning it Falls ran that
offense most recently 2016 in Kansas
City when Falls played during a time
that Alex Smith had a concussion and
Matt naggy oh by the way was the
offensive coordinator the Bears at the
era of the Chiefs excuse me at the time
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports